This is the northern bald eagle.
An iconic bird
that we almost lost for good only a few decades ago,
northern bald eagles are the larger of the two subspecies of the bald eagle.
Their wingspan can reach over seven feet.
They are powerful flyers that soar through the air, reaching over 40 miles per hour when gliding.
They’re excellent predators, attacking from above with their long and sharp talons.
By the 1960s, their population was decimated
with less than 1000 left in the wild.
Chemicals from pesticides traveled up the food chain rendering these top predators sterile
or unable to lay healthy eggs.
Thankfully, after massive regulations were put in place they have made a near full recovery.
Today, loss of suitable habitat is still a threat
as they are very sensitive to human activity.
This is the northern bald eagle.